el momento de su independencia del
imperio británico en 1963 y tras haber
sido su economía además devastada por la
ocupación japonesa durante la segunda
guerra mundial
singapur no era más que una aglomeración
de chabolas donde cocinas y baños tenían
que ser compartidas por varias familias
el momento singapur se unió a malasia
pero apenas dos años después en 1965 y
tras diversos enfrentamientos políticos
y étnicos con el aristócrata y
extractivo el gobierno de malasia
singapur fue expulsada de la federación
malaya y obligada de facto a declararse
independiente en ese momento el desafío
que se le presentaba a este pequeño
territorio era enorme
singapur en el lugar pobre tenía menos
de dos millones de habitantes y carecía
de todo recurso natural ni siquiera un
territorio que es suficiente respecto a
la alimentación y el agua
sin embargo pese a todo apenas cinco
décadas después
singapur es una de las capitales del
mundo y uno de los territorios más ricos
atentos de hecho al siguiente gráfico
que refleja su impresionante éxito
económico y la diferencia con muchos de
nuestros países
y es que desde 1960 la economía de
singapur ha crecido más de un 75 por
ciento cada año convirtiéndose así en el
proceso de desarrollo más rápido de toda
la historia hoy la renta per cápita de
esta ciudad-estado es muy superior a la
de eeuu más que implicara de españa y
que así multiplica por cuatro la de
chile que es el líder latinoamericano
sencillamente que es impresionante
como ha logrado semejante desarrollo
lee kuan yew el primer ministro de
singapur entre 1959 y 1990 y además
considerado el gran artífice de este
milagro económico y coqueteó en un
primer momento con las llamadas
políticas y si esto es de
industrialización por sustitución de
importaciones que mediante el
proteccionismo tratan de impulsar el
desarrollo y que han sido muy populares
en américa latina durante todo el siglo
20 y de hecho en cierto modo aún lo
siguen siendo por ejemplo en países como
ecuador las autoridades económicas del
país confirmaron que 2.800 sus partidas
o líneas de productos que ingresan al
país estarán gravadas con aranceles o
sobre tasas sin embargo pronto se dio
cuenta de que este tipo de iniciativas
no resultaban el mejor camino para
desarrollar un país sumida en la pobreza
por eso a partir de 1965 se puso en
marcha el enfoque de éxito que
transformó singapur la apertura al
mercado global
ahora bien ojo porque sin apuro no ha
sido ni mucho menos un prototipo de
estado libertario ortodoxo donde el
gobierno no se entromete en la actividad
económica al contrario que el gobierno
de singapur ha jugado un papel muy
destacado y en muchos casos declaró el
liderazgo pero antes de que lances
encima mío
con un enfoque muy diferente de lo que
estamos acostumbrados las cosas están
cambiando rápido y estamos teniendo que
ajustarnos y seguir el ritmo debido a la
tecnología a la globalización tenemos
que anticipar qué está sucediendo
tenemos que ayudar a las empresas y
trabajadores a adaptarse en singapur el
gobierno no jugó ocupar parte las cada
vez mayores de la economía ni era
regular todos y cada uno de los espacios
hasta el mínimo detalle ni a expandir
por supuesto el gasto público y los
impuestos todo lo contrario en el caso
de singapur prácticamente podemos hablar
de la adquisición por parte de los
poderes públicos de una noción de estado
empresa o mejor dicho en este caso de
ciudad empresa la compañía es de ustedes
de ustedes los accionistas es decir lee
kuan yew entendió que singapur
necesitaba atraer capitales y
profesionales para poder crecer y
desarrollarse y que precisamente en un
marco de competencia y perfecta entre
economías y países muy intervenidos el
estado podía jugar un papel clave eso sí
con políticas que favorecen la
competitividad la inversión y la
atracción de empresas
gracián en el asistencialismo me encanta
que los planes salgan bien así por
ejemplo las autoridades singapurenses
desarrollaron instituciones que tenían
como fin garantizar la seguridad
jurídica y una gestión eficiente de la
ciudad promovieron sectores económicos
determinados mediante la colaboración
público-privado trazaron un ambicioso
programa de infraestructuras productivas
que impulsaron el ahorro eso sí todas
las políticas se diseñaron en un marco
de estricta estabilidad presupuestaria y
siempre pensando en su integración con
los agentes privados algo que rara vez
ocurre por ejemplo en españa pero señor
alcalde es que una costa es una costa y
que pues se hace pero como traemos el
mar han puesto una playa en madrid es
decir no se trata tanto de ampliar algún
puerto como de integrar un marco
jurídico institucional atractivo con
servicios que conduzcan a las empresas a
instalarse en un país en este caso
singapur y aquí crezcan en productividad
insisto la diferencia es muy importante
prácticamente podemos decir que el
estado de singapur es un proveedor de
servicios con vocación competitiva en
singapur el gobierno entendió que la
propia comunidad
ciudad institucional en activo y que
bien gestionada podría convertirse en
toda una ventaja competitiva
podemos poner como ejemplo dos políticas
primero lograr que la ciudad a pesar de
contar con una altísima densidad de
población no fue su lugar caótico
ruidoso y contaminado para ello ya en
1975 pusieron trabas a la congestión y
hoy el tráfico está sometido a peajes
que se cobran electrónicamente a todos
los usuarios de la vía todos los
vehículos es decir de esta forma se
imputaron los costos de mantenimiento de
las calles de las carreteras a los
usuarios reales de las mismas al tiempo
que lograban evitar los atascos y gran
parte de la contaminación
como encandilado s subaru el resultado
es que y singapur tiene un tráfico muy
fluido y que éste se distribuye conforme
al valor que le genera cada usuario la
utilización de la misma carretera por
supuesto al tiempo singapur desarrolló
un excelente eficiente y asequible
sistema de transporte público otra
medida mucho más controvertida por su
paternalismo fue obligar a todos los
trabajadores a invertir un cuarto de su
salario en un rígido plan de ahorro
nacional que es gestionado además por
una organización estatal con este
programa el gobierno de la isla persigue
que los trabajadores conformen un
patrimonio con lo que poder sufragar
servicios sanitarios servicios
educativos así como la propia jubilación
y mientras eso ocurre el estado obtiene
los recursos necesarios para invertir
dentro y fuera del país en proyectos que
se entienden son esenciales para la
competitividad de la ciudad en cierto
modo de esta forma los trabajadores
pasan a ser no sólo usuarios sino
también inversores en esta ciudad
empresa
por supuesto este tipo de intervenciones
donde el estado mantiene un acusado
liderazgo son complementadas con una
política decidida en favor de la libre
empresa y una de las regulaciones más
libres del mundo en materia de
circulación de capitales mercancías y
trabajadores en singapur los impuestos
son reducidos por ejemplo una renta de
60 mil dólares viene a pagar un 5 por
ciento del impuesto de la renta los
aranceles son prácticamente inexistentes
no hay salario mínimo el gasto público
ojo supone aproximadamente un 18% del
pib es la segunda economía más libre del
mundo y según el banco mundial es el
país donde más fácil resulta hacer
negocios y casi nada miren en el mundo
que vivimos hoy ser periférico o ser
central no depende de la ubicación
física de tu país depende que si tienes
o no una educación y una economía del
conocimiento depende de la tecnología es
lo único que puede explicar que países
como singapur tengan mucha mejor
educación que nosotros el resultado de
todo ello es que un país que hasta hace
unas pocas décadas era muy pobre hoy es
uno de los más ricos del mundo cuenta
con varias universidades entre las
sus estudiantes están a la cabeza en
materias como ciencias y matemáticas su
sistema sanitario es considerado
excelente no hay paro no hay
delincuencia y las expectativas son
extraordinarias por ejemplo en el índice
de desarrollo humano elaborado por
naciones unidas- ocupa la plaza 11 por
encima de países como suecia islandia
francia finlandia de hecho os puedo
asegurar que en pocos sitios he
experimentado tanto la movilidad social
y las oportunidades de crecimiento
profesional como cuando estaba en este
pequeño estado
hoy se ha convertido en toda una
potencia industrial comercial y
turística
aspectos negativos de la cara negativa
que la tiene se concentra en el sistema
político que aunque está evolucionando
sigue siendo muy restrictivo con las
libertades civiles en singapur las penas
de cárcel son altísimas en la censura es
normal y los comportamientos diferentes
no suelen ser bien considerados de todo
esto y demás hablaremos en futuros
vídeos porque desde luego singapur es
uno de los países más fascinantes de
todo el mundo y un auténtico imán para
los profesionales de todos los lugares
bueno a ti qué te parece crees que
singapur es un modelo a seguir crees que
el estado tiene que gestionar el
patrimonio público para lograr extraer
rendimientos como si de una empresa se
tratara tiene efectos leves a esta
ciudad empresa y espero que te haya
gustado el vídeo si ha sido así y dale a
like y no te olvides de estar atento a
nuestras novedades en facebook y en
twitter un saludo y hasta la próxima